amazon virtual private cloud is a
service that lets you launch aws
resources in a logically isolated
virtual network that you define
neil davis teaches this course he's
created many popular aws courses and
he's a great teacher this is neil davis
from digital cloud training in this
hands-on video you're going to learn
amazon virtual private cloud vpc
in aws a vpc is a logically isolated
portion of the cloud into which you can
deploy your own resources such as amazon
ec2 instances vpc is quite a complex
topic in this video i'm going to start
right at the beginner level and take you
through to an intermediary or even
expert level you'll learn how to define
your own ip address ranges for a vpc how
to create a vpc and launch resources
into it you'll learn about routing in
vpcs security groups network access
control lists and will also cover vpn
connections direct connect and much more
this video comes from my brand new aws
certified solutions architects associate
course so if you're planning to take an
aws certification exam this video will
be very very useful for you but it's
good for anybody who wants to learn
about amazon vpc and actually practice
using it for those who want to learn
even more there are some supplementary
videos on the digital cloud training
youtube channel
including for creating a client vpn and
a site-to-site vpn both hands-on videos
you can find the links to those videos
in the description of this video and
you'll also find the course download as
well which you'll need to complete the
hands-on exercises in this course
now i really hope that you enjoy this
video and let's get straight into it
hi guys in this lesson i'm going to
cover a basic primer on ip addressing
and we are specifically talking about
ipv version 4 not version 6. i'll cover
version 6 a bit later on in this section
now what i want to do here is assume
that you don't have much knowledge of ip
addressing at all if any
and i'm going to start right at the
basics now it is a really complex
subject so i'm only going to go as far
as what you need to know in order to be
competent working with amazon vpc and
with ip addressing in general with aws
now there'll be some areas of the
subject matter where you may want to go
deeper and there's lots of resources on
the internet for doing that if you wish
to
to kick off the lesson let's start with
what is an ip address
now let's say we have a web server on
the internet and you want to communicate
with that web server now the web server
is likely to have some kind of network
interface
and attached to that network interface
will be an ip address
and this is going to be a public ip
address in this case because the web
server is available via the internet ip
addresses are the addresses that
computers use to communicate with each
other
so you've got your computer at home and
you've got a web browser open and you
type in example.com the address of our
web server now what happens now because
you've put in example.com but like i
said the computers communicate using ip
addresses
so this is where a domain name system or
dns server comes in your computer will
speak to a dns server and it's going to
ask that dns server what is the ip
address for example.com
once your computer has the result it's
then able to connect to the web server
using the ip address so this is domain
name resolution where you're resolving a
name a nice friendly name that you can
remember easily into an ip address which
is less easy to remember but it's the
way computers actually communicate with
each other
let's move on to the structure of an ip
address now you've very likely seen ip
addresses we've already worked with them
in this course
so an ip address might look like this
192.168.0.1
this is known as dotted decimal notation
and it's a simple way of actually
representing an ip address now each of
these parts between the dots is actually
a binary octet so that's where things
get a little bit more complex but you do
need to know this
so
what is a binary octane
well octet means that you have eight
values and those values can either be a
one or they can be a zero those are the
only two options it's binary in this
small table here you can see that in
this case we have ones eight ones all in
a line
now on the left hand side we have what's
called the most significant bit
that means if a 1 is in this leftmost
place
it's going to have a value of 128.
if you have a 1 on the right hand side
that's the least significant bit and its
value is only one
if you have a zero anywhere it just
means zero
so for example in this address the third
octa is a zero so that means all of the
eight bits are zeros
the one means that all seven bits here
are zeros and we have a one on the right
hand side and that equals this least
significant bit here
on the very left we have 192
well 192 is 128 plus 64. so we have a
one and a one
and the remaining values are zeros
and then for 168 we have a one so that's
128 then we have a one in the third
place here which is 32 and then we have
a one in the fifth place here which is
eight
so we have 128 plus 32 plus eight equals
168.
the reason it's important to understand
this binary is when we get to subnetting
with variable length subnet masks that's
coming shortly so firstly let's
understand the network and host portions
of an ip address
every ip address has a network id and a
host id
the free blue boxes on the left here
represent the network id this value will
be the same for every computer on this
network the host id will be unique for
every computer on this network as i said
before every ip address will have a
network and host id but how this is
configured does vary
now how do we know which piece is the
network id and which is the host id well
that's where the subnet mask comes into
play
where we have two five five in this case
essentially where we have a bit that is
a one
that represents the network id
so here we have eight bits that are one
eight bits that are one and eight bits
that are one so those first three octets
are all representing the network id
now the last octa in the orange box here
is going to be the host id that's why
it's a zero
so every bit in the subnet mask that is
a zero
means that's where we have values that
can be assigned to hosts and every bit
that's a one
those are values that are going to be
exactly the same for every computer on
the network so a subnet mask is an easy
way to see which bit is the network and
which portion is the host id
so let's look at an example we have our
zero 192.1680 network with a subnet mask
that looks like this
now this is 24 bits a 24 bit subnet mask
because we have eight ones in those
first three octets
and that means it's a slash 24 network
it's another way of representing the
subnet mask
and that's the format you'll often work
with in aws
so on this network we might have several
computers and we can see that they each
have different host ids but the same
network id
in this case the host ids are one two
three four five six and the network id
is 192.1680
for all of the hosts on the network we
also have something called classes with
ip addresses class a looks like this
1000
and
25500 essentially you have an 8 bit
subnet mask
and that means the first assignable
address is going to be a one you can't
ever assign zero as an address for a
computer on the network
and the last assignable address is going
to be 254
because you can't use 255 which is
what's known as the broadcast address
now in aws there's also a few other
addresses that are reserved
with a class a subnet mask you can have
up to 126
networks
and each of those networks can have a
huge number of hosts sixteen million
seven hundred and seventy seven thousand
two hundred and fourteen
and that's because we have all of these
bits here to play with for the host id
we then got class b
which has a 16 bit subnet mask
first assignable address is 172 1601 for
this example
and the last address would be the 254
here we have 16
382 networks so a lot more networks and
the usable addresses per network has
reduced to 65 534
lastly we have a class c this has a
24-bit subnet mask
and as you can see the number of
networks is now really increased but we
don't have as many addresses available
per network
so those are the standard classes
now there's also something called a
private ip address range there's a few
of these that are reserved for private
use that means not on the internet
internally within your company we have
10 triple zero to ten two five five two
five five two five five one seven two
sixteen zero zero to one seven two
thirty two two five five two five five
and then one nine two one six eight zero
zero three to one nine 192-1680-255
these addresses are reserved for use in
private networks so not internet facing
you can't use these on the public
internet things now get a little bit
more complicated sometimes we want to
vary the length of our subnet masks and
we don't want to stick to those standard
classes so we use something called
classless inter-domain routing and this
helps us optimize the ip space
let's have a look at some examples
let's say we have this network here
with a 24-bit subnet mask
we have eight host bits and 254 possible
addresses
the first address is dot one the last is
dot two five four pretty standard so far
we then have a 16 bit subnet mask so
with the same network we're using a
different subnet mask a non-standard one
in this case because
192.168 is typically a class c network
with a 16 bit subnet mask we have 16
host bits and up to 65
534 addresses
and it looks like this
but what about a slash 20 subnet mask
well here as you can see we have a blue
slash orange box and that's because we
borrowed some bits from the network id
to share them and use them for the host
id
that means we now have 12 host bits and
4094 addresses so sometimes that's a
better configuration for the number of
computers you need to have on the
network and the number of networks you
actually need
and the addresses for this network would
start at 0 1 and go up to 15.254
so that's classless inter-domain routing
or cider and it's using variable length
subnet masks in other words breaking
away from the standard and optimizing
the amount of networks and hosts that we
have
now i know that's quite complex and
hopefully it will make more sense as we
go through the section so that's it for
this particular lesson i hope you got
lots of value from that and i'll see you
in the next lesson
hi guys in this lesson i'm going to
teach you about the amazon virtual
private cloud or vpc vpc incorporates
several different concepts
and what we're going to do in this
section is go into them in much more
detail so first we'll start off with the
core knowledge around vpc itself
so within a region we have our vpcs and
they are always within a region they
can't span across regions
a vpc is essentially a logically
isolated portion of the aws cloud that
you can then use to deploy your
resources inside it
and that's different to the public space
outside of the vpc where services like
amazon s3 set
this is a private space and you have
full control over how you configure your
vpc now as you know within a region we
have availability zones and you can use
those within your vpc
by creating subnets and assigning those
subnets to an availability zone a subnet
is always assigned to one availability
zone it can't span across multiple azs
but you can of course have multiple
subnets in the same az we then deploy
our resources such as ec2 instances into
our subnets
now there's a thing called the vpc
router
you don't really see the vpc router but
it exists
and we interact with it by configuring
route tables now the vpc router takes
care of all routing for connections that
are going outside of a subnet if you
send data out of a subnet it's got to go
somewhere else maybe to another subnet
or maybe out to the internet or some
other network
so the router takes care of making sure
the data connection is sent to the right
place
now as i said you don't see the vpc
router all you do is see the route
tables and they are configuring the vpc
router for you
so we need to specify the destinations
and the targets for certain networks and
that's how it then knows where to send
those connection attempts
if we want to access the internet we
also need an internet gateway the
internet gateway is attached to your vpc
you only ever have one per vpc the
internet gateway is used for sending
data out to the internet that's egress
traffic and in from the internet that's
ingress traffic and we configure our
route table with a route to the internet
gateway id that tells it to send all
traffic that doesn't fit one of the
networks in the route table before it
to the internet gateway
now you can create multiple vpcs within
a region you have a limit of 5 by
default but you can request an increase
on that amount each vpc has a cider
block that's the overall block of
addresses from which you then create the
addresses you assign to your subnet so
it's kind of like a master block of
addresses each vpc has a different one
of these so in this case we got two vpcs
and they have different cider blocks as
you learned in the last lesson cider
stands for classless inter-domain
routing from the overall cider block we
can then create the network ids for our
subnets and they fit within that overall
cider block but they have a different
subnet mask so they're essentially a
subset of the overall available
addresses and this is why it's really
important to make sure we specify our
cider blocks correctly so we have enough
networks and enough hosts per network
we'll cover that in another lesson
so here we have two vpcs each with
different cider blocks and then each
with different subnets that come from
those cider blocks now we're going to
cover a lot of these components within
this section but i just want to cover
them at a high level now so you know
what a vpc is and what subnets are you
know what an internet gateway is as well
now an egress only internet gateway is
when you're using the ipv6 protocol
and it allows traffic outbound only
whereas an internet gateway is for ipv
version 4 and it allows both egress and
ingress traffic as you know the router
the vpc router takes care of routing
connections to the right places
now appearing connection is something
where you can connect multiple vpcs and
have private routing between them we'll
cover that in detail later on in the
section
vpc endpoints allow you to connect using
private ip addresses to public services
on aws again we'll cover that in detail
later on now nat instances and gateways
we covered these earlier in the course
these are both ways that you can enable
internet connectivity outbound only
for your instances in private subnets
the next two components the virtual
private gateway and the customer gateway
are both related to creating virtual
private network vpn connections to our
company offices or our company data
centers so that's a virtually private
network an encrypted tunnel over the
internet we then have direct connect
that avoids the internet by using
private connections right the way
through to your data center or office
and security groups and network acls are
two different types of firewall we'll
cover them in a bit more detail in this
section we've used security groups quite
a lot so far they are what we call a
instance level firewall because they
operate at the level of the network
interface attached to our ec2 instances
then we have the network acl that's a
subnet level firewall so it only sees
traffic going in and out of the subnet
so just to summarize that core knowledge
a vpc is a virtual network dedicated to
your aws account
it's similar to having your own data
center inside aws because you're able to
have full control over what you do with
defining your cider blocks creating your
own subnets setting up your security
your routing and so on you have lots and
lots of control
it's logically isolated from other
virtual networks in the aws cloud
and as i mentioned before you get full
control over lots of the configuration
items in your vpc and a vpc is a place
where you then launch your resources
such as amazon ec2 instances when you
create a vpc you must specify your cider
block so that's the overall block of
addresses now we'll see how to select
the best cider block for our use case in
another lesson
a vpc spans all azs within a region that
essentially means if there's three or
six or whatever number of azs in a
region you can create subnets within
your vpc on all of those azs
but remember each subnet is always
within one az it can't span azs but you
create multiple subnets if you want to
in an availability zone you get full
control over access to your resources
inside of epc as well
and by default you can create five per
region but you can extend that if you
submit a request
a default vpc is created in each region
with a subnet in each availability zone
and that's always a public subnet so
whichever region we've changed to you'll
find this already a default vpc and it
already has a number of public subnets
in it now that's it for this lesson in
the next lesson we'll have a look at how
we can work out a suitable cider block
for our use case
in this lesson we're going to look at
what we need to do to define the cider
blocks we're going to use a few of the
rules and guidelines and best practices
so first with the rules and guidelines
and these come from
the cider block size can be between a 16
and slash 28 subnet mask
it cannot overlap with any existing
cider block that's associated with the
vpc
and you cannot increase or decrease the
size of an existing cider block so you
must get it right from the beginning the
first four and last ip address are not
available for use so you've got to
account for that when you set the size
of your subnets because you want to make
sure you have enough addresses for your
instances that you deploy
aws recommend that you use cider blocks
from the rc 1918 ranges remember these
are the private ip ranges
and that's these addresses and of course
these give you plenty of scope so that
shouldn't be a problem now let's have a
look at an example so let's say i have a
vpc cider block that looks like this
it's
zero zero with a 16 bit subnet mask
so
that means it looks like this ten zero
zero zero slash sixteen so that's the
overall block of addresses but now we
wanna create our subnets so what we need
to do there is we're going to take some
of the bits from the host portion here
and assign them to the network portion
so maybe we're going to have 10 0 1
0
24 and that means we borrowed all eight
bits from that third octet for the
network id so your vpc subnets will have
a longer subnet mask than the cider
block that they come from now in this
case it's a 24 bit subnet mask
now what's the next network the next
network is 10 0 2 0 24 and then the next
one is 10 0 3 0 24
so each of these subnets is going to
have up to
254 potential hosts but of course you
have to take away a few from that number
so take away five from that number and
that's how many addresses you have
remaining for your ec2 instances so as
long as you're happy with that number of
instances per network which is quite a
big number still
then this is a good and very simple
range to use now let's go through a few
additional considerations you got to
ensure you have enough networks and
hosts you really don't want to mess this
up you only get to set this side block
once and then you're stuck with it so
make sure you plan correctly bigger
cider blocks are typically better it
gives you more flexibility down the road
smaller subnets are okay for most use
cases you don't need thousands of
instances per subnet
consider deploying application tiers per
subnet so if you have a free tier
application you might have different
subnets for each tier and you might have
it as highly available across multiple
availability zones as well with a subnet
in each az so that's a good way of
getting that high availability and
resilience into your workload
now vpc pairing which we're going to
cover a bit later is where you connect
your vpcs so that you can route directly
between them using private ip addresses
so you don't go out to the public
internet now it's really essential that
you don't have overlapping cider blocks
so in other words you can't have the
same cider block in two vpcs and connect
them with vpc peering so even if you're
not doing pairing now just remember this
because you might need to do it in the
future
you want to make sure your cider blocks
don't overlap and this is across all
vpcs in all regions and all accounts so
make sure you get it correct
so in general just avoid overlapping
cider blocks as much as possible make
sure you consider this when you're
designing your ip address ranges
so let's go back to an example let's say
we have ten zero zero zero
slash sixteen so that's our cider block
and we create a series of subnets now
each of these subnets has a 24-bit
subnet mask
and as you can see we're separating them
into public and private subnets in
different availability zones the private
subnets have a private route table and
the public ones have a different route
table of course the main route table for
the public subnets here will have an
internet gateway and those subnets will
also assign public ip addresses to the
instances that are launched in them so
that's a bit of theory behind it and
some practical examples here i also want
to show you a very useful tool that
helps you to plan out your cider blocks
and your subnets
i'll attach a link to this tool to the
lesson
now what we can do with this tool is
specify our cider block and see the
subnets and we can actually
the tool will help us to work out which
subnets to use based on the number of
networks we need subnets or the number
of hosts per network
so let's stick with the example and put
in 10.0.0.0
and then subnet mask we're going to
scroll down to slash 16.
now i want to have subnets with at least
254 hosts so that would be a standard
class c network
now let's have a look what we get so
let's click on create
and it gives us all the subnets with a
slash 24-bit subnet mask that fit within
this cider block
so we've got the zero subnet here and
then all the way down we get to the very
last subnet
which is 255 so that's 255
subnets that we can have and each of
those subnets can support up to 254
hosts of course the vpc will actually
reserve a few addresses so you won't get
that many but you'll still get close to
250. so that's a really nice tool to use
to help you to work out what your
subnets are going to be within your
cider block and that will also help you
to determine the best cider block as
well
hi guys in this lesson i'm going to show
you how to use the vpc wizard the wizard
helps you to really easily create a vpc
without having to do much manual work at
all in my management console let's go
down to networking and vpc on the vpc
dashboard here i can choose launch vpc
wizard
and we then get offered four different
pre-configured options and what i want
to do is just go through what you get
with each of these options so the first
one is a vpc with a single public subnet
very simple you get a slash 16 cider
block and a slash 24 subnet and it's a
public subnet
so if you select this option
you can specify your cider block and
it's giving you this default
you can specify a name it's already
entered the subnet cider block as well
you could choose an az if you want to or
otherwise after entering the name you
could literally just create the vpc and
it's going to do all the tasks for you
and that would include attaching an
internet gateway so that you have
internet connectivity for your public
subnet
now let's cancel out of there or let's
go back
go to vpc with public and private
subnets so now you simply get public and
private subnets and you get a network
address translation device so you get a
nat gateway so your private instances
can access the internet so again with
this option there's not too much to
configure other than the different
subnets public and private the key
difference here is your nat gateway does
need an elastic ip so you need an
elastic ip allocation id
now let's go back again
and this time we're going to go to vpc
with public and private subnets and
hardware vpn access
here you have public subnets private
subnets and also a vpn tunnel gets
created now you need to have a vpn
device in your corporate data center
if we select this option
and let's just give this a name myvpc
and leave the defaults on this page
click on next
and then it's going to ask for the
customer gateway ip and that's the ip
address of your vpn device on your side
of the network on your corporate data
center so
if you specify those details when you
create this vpc it's going to make that
connection
let's just go back
back again
and the last one at the bottom is vpc
with a private subnet only and hardware
vpn access
the same as the one before except that
you only have a private subnet so you've
got a vpn connection from your corporate
data center to a private subnet on aws
with no routing going out via the
internet from that subnet in aws
so those are the four options i just
wanted to quickly show you through them
and in the next lesson we'll actually
create our own custom vpc
in this lesson we're going to create a
custom vpc with public and private
subnets now let's have a look at what
we're going to create
so we're going to use the same example
cider block we've seen in the section
it's going to be a 10 0 0 0 network with
a 16-bit subnet mask that's the overall
block of addresses
then we're going to create these four
subnets we've got private 1a and private
1b and public 1a and public 1b
and the 1a and the 1b mean that they're
associated with a specific availability
zone
now for the private subnets we'll have a
private route table
for the public subnets we'll have this
main route table that's created by
default we'll attach an internet gateway
to our vpc
and the main route table will have a
route via the internet gateway out to
the internet for those public subnets we
also must specify that we want our
instances to pick up a public ip address
automatically so that's the
configuration let's head over to the
console and build this out in the vpc
dashboard i'm going to go to your vpcs
and we just have a single default vpc so
let's create a new one in your course
download in the code directory amazon
vpc you'll have this file custom vpc
we can simply copy values so i've got
the name that's going to go under name
tag let's copy the cider block and put
that under ipv4 cider block we're not
going to do ipv6 at this stage in this
course
we'll leave the tenancy as default if
you change to dedicated it's going to
put your instances on hardware that's
dedicated to you and that's going to
cost you more money so definitely leave
that as default
and that's all we need to do to create
the vpc so the vpc is being created
one thing i like to do is go to actions
edit dns host names and enable that
means we'll get dns hostnames for our
ec2 instances the next task is to create
our subnets we've got public subnets and
private subnets so i'm just going to
copy these values to my clipboard we'll
come back go down to subnets
create subnet we need to specify our vpc
so myvpc
and then we can put in the name
under subnet name choose the
availability zone as one a usc 1a
and then the ipbs4 cider block we'll
come back
we'll copy this cider block and we'll
paste that in now we could create the
subnet there or we can add a new one and
we're just going to do the same for the
next three subnets so just go through
this file and copy these settings for
your additional free subnets
when you've finished your page should
look like this you've got public 1a in
usc 1a with a 10 0 1 cider block and
then you've got
subnet 2 public 1b and that should be in
usc 1b so let's modify that and 10.02
private 1a
should also be in u.s east 1a 103 and
then private 1b
in u.s east 1b 104. so that all looks
good let's create all four subnets and
that's the four subnets created now for
our public subnets we want to go to
actions here modify auto assign ip
settings and enable the auto assignment
of public ipv4 addresses so i've done
that for public 1b let's do it for
public one a
and those are updated now
so the next thing i want to do
is i need to create a route table for my
private subnets so they're not attached
to the main route table which is where
the public subnets will be
so let's go to route tables
create route table
we're going to specify a name i have
that in my clipboard from the file
private rt
for vpc i'm going to select my vpc
and then we'll create the route table
once that's created go to subnet
associations
edit subnet associations
and you want to select private1b and
private1a
and save
so now we've done that if we go into
subnet associations we should see an
explicit association for private1a and b
if we come back up to route tables we'll
see the other route table here so this
is the main route table or the public
route table if you like
and under subnet associations there are
no explicit subnet associations but 1a
and 1b public are associated implicitly
the next thing i need to do
is go and create an internet gateway so
under internet gateways here let's
create an internet gateway
we'll give it a name and let's just
paste this value in from the file
and create internet gateway once it's
been created it needs to be attached
under actions you can attach to vpc
select the vpc
and then attach the internet gateway
now the last thing we need to do now we
have an internet gateway we do need a
route from our main route table so let's
go to the main route table here
go to routes
edit routes
add a route and we'll put in
the zero zero zero zero
zero
choose our internet gateway and there it
is in the list
so now
everything within the cider block will
be routed locally by the vpc router and
everything that's not within that vpc
cider block will go out to the internet
via the internet gateway so let's just
save those changes so that's it we've
created our custom vpc with public
subnets private subnets two route tables
and an internet gateway
now that's all i need to do for this
particular lesson in the next lesson
what i'd like to do is launch some
instances and just test our
configuration and make sure we have the
communication we expect
so we've created our custom vpc and i
just like to test it now so we're going
to launch some ec2 instances two
instances and two different public
subnets and one in a private subnet and
we're actually going to do that via the
command line it's really useful to know
the command line now not all exams
require you to know the command line so
for the solutions architect associate
doesn't really matter too much for the
developer it does a bit more for certain
services and definitely for the sysops
exam now whatever exam you're doing or
whatever career path you're taking in
aws it's still a really useful skill to
have so it's definitely worth learning
the command line
so we'll launch some instances using the
command line and then we'll use those
instances just to test connectivity with
each other there's a couple of things i
want to do before we get started there
firstly i want to create a nat gateway
so i'm in the vpc management console
under net gateways let's create a net
gateway i'm just going to call it my nat
gw
and i need to select a subnet now
remember with nat gateways they always
go in public subnets so here i'm going
to choose public 1a
and that i know is within the correct
vpc as well
so connectivity is public we allocate an
elastic ip and then just create the net
gateway now of course it won't work
until we update the route table for our
private subnets so under route tables
let's choose the private rt
go to routes
edit routes
add route
and we're going to specify zero zero
zero zero and this time it's going to be
a nat gateway and would choose that nat
gateway id
now our private subnets will have access
to the internet and that's important
because when our instance launches we're
going to run some user data and that's
going to connect to the internet to
download some binaries for httpd
next thing is under security groups we
need a security group
let's create a security group i'm going
to call it public web give it a
description
and make sure i select my vpc
for outbound rules by default it allows
all traffic to any destination
for inbound just for now we're going to
add all traffic
from any destination so this is very
open don't worry we're going to lock it
down in a subsequent lesson and practice
with some different security group
configurations but for now let's just
open everything up
i'm going to create my security group
and that's ready to use there's a file
in your course download and that's in
the code amazon vpc directory and it's
aws cli run instances
we need to add some values into this
file the first thing we need to do for
this command is specify an image id so
the command is aws ec2 run dash
instances and these are the values that
we need to specify so first let's find
the ami id that we want to use ami ids
are region specific so we've got to make
sure that everything we do in this
lesson is within the same region it's
also where you created your custom vpc
so for me that's north virginia
hopefully it's the same for you
let's launch an instance
next to the amazon linux 2 ami
let's grab this ami id don't take
anything in brackets there copy that to
the clipboard
come back and paste that in
the instance type we can just type this
in it's just going to be t2 dot micro
for security group ids let's go back and
find the id of our security group i can
see my public web access security group
let's just copy the security group id
come back
and paste that one in then we need the
subnet id this time i'm back in the vpc
management console let's go to subnets
first i want the public 1a
subnet id
so i'm just going to copy that to my
clipboard key name is the key pair that
you're using in this specific region
back in ec2 you can go to key pairs if
you don't remember what it is
and just copy this name and we can paste
that in lastly there's some user data
that we're going to specify
now this is the user data file what it
does is runs a web server and then it
creates a couple of variables from the
metadata where it actually grabs the
subnet id and it basically just puts
that into a simple web page so we can
see where the instance is running in our
command here we just need to specify the
name of that file now what you want to
do is change to your amazon vpc
directory where we have all of this
information and this is where the file
is so copy that to your clipboard make
sure you have the file colon slash
and then the name of your file
now let's copy this and make sure it
works before we fill out the other two
now you will have had to run aws
configure before you do this exercise
you should have specified an access key
id secret access key
and your region must be the same as the
region where we're trying to deploy our
instances now
so mine's all good let's paste in this
command
and run the command and that appears
successful and we can see that we have
an instance running in usc 1a and
there's quite a bit of information if
you just spacebar and go down the page
here so let's go into ec2 and check it's
launching back in ec2 i can see i have
this instance at the bottom here running
now i'm just going to label this one as
public
a so i know which one it is now the next
thing we need to do
is to go back over to the vpc management
console
take the subnet id
of public 1b and come back to our file
and we're going to use this one
so what we can do is copy
all of this
put it in 1b here
and then i'm going to take this subnet
id and just override this one here so we
should now be able to launch into public
1b let's copy this to our clipboard come
back and paste it in that looks good if
i refresh the page here and we have this
pending instance
that's the public 1b so i'll just give
that a label so we know which one it is
and then lastly we're going to
launch the instance in our private
subnet so again i just need to get the
subnet id
for private1b so i've copied that to my
clipboard come back paste that in and
now we have the command and this user
data should run okay in the private
subnet because we're able to connect out
to the internet via the nat gateway so i
paste this in hit enter
there we go we should have another
instance
back in ec2 i can see my pending
instance here so let's call this one
private
1b great so i have these instances let's
just give a refresh and see where we're
at so a couple of them are running let's
sort by name that might make things a
bit easier i'm just going to copy to my
clipboard the public ip for public 1a
and paste this into a browser window and
i get this webpage and it gives me the
subnet id so that should correspond
with the subnet for public 1a so that's
great we've proved that we can connect
from the internet to our ec2 instance
now the other thing i want to do is
connect between my ec2 instances back in
the console here what i'm going to do is
connect to public 1a use the ec2
instance connect and while that's just
connecting
let's come back
next i want to get the private ip
address of my public 1b instance and
that's 10.025
and let's just change back to the ec2
instance connect
and i'm going to ping
10.0.2.25
and let's see if that responds
so that proves that we have connectivity
to our instance in the other public
subnet public subnet 1b so we have
two-way connectivity the response is
coming back as well so that's great
lastly let's check that we can connect
to our private subnet so let's see what
the private ip address is it's 104 148
so let's ping
10.0
and let's see if that works and it does
so we get an icmp response so that's
great that shows that we have that
connectivity working
one other thing we could do from here is
see if we can connect to that web page
so we'll use the curl command and
specify 10.0.4.148
and hit enter
and we get a response here that says
this instance is in the subnet with id
and it gives us the subnet id so that's
the h1 header for the html web page that
we have on that website so we can see
that we have port 80 open as well we're
able to connect to the instance in the
private subnet and we can also infer
from that that the instance can connect
out to the internet because it was able
to install that web service so that's it
for our connectivity testing for now now
i'm going to leave all of these
instances and then that gateway running
because we're going to come back and
carry on when we do some testing with
security groups and network acls
hi guys security groups and network
access control lists acls are two
different types of firewall that we can
apply in our aws environment so let's
have a look at how they work so here we
have a vpc with two availability zones
we've got a couple of public and private
subnets and we've got a few ec2
instances that have been launched into
different public subnets and private
subnets
so let's see how we can control traffic
firstly we can apply something called a
network access control list and network
acl
now these get applied at the subnet
level so you can see that they're
sitting here at the edge of the subnet
now all traffic that goes into
and out of a subnet will go through a
network acl
so you're essentially filtering traffic
as it enters or exits the subnet so
ingress and egress traffic a security
group is different
a security group actually applies at the
instance level of an ec2 instance
actually at the network interface level
of the ec2 instance
so that means we can have a security
group that is applied to ec2 instances
in different subnets so this is the same
security group security group a and it's
been applied to instances in several
different subnets
so remember that this is the instance
level that means it's going to filter
traffic going between instances in the
same subnet or across different subnets
we could then have security group b
that's attached to different instances
so security groups can be applied to
instances in any subnet now what happens
here with these security groups is the
same basic thing as a network acl
they're looking for traffic that's going
in and out of the security group so if
you send traffic from an instance in
security group a to an instance in
security group b
it's going to check that there's a rule
to allow the outbound traffic and then
it's going to check here the security
group b is going to check am i going to
allow the traffic from security group a
and you can do that by ip address or you
can actually do it by the id of the
security group itself we'll look at all
this in detail in the hands-on as well
now i want to talk to you about stateful
versus state less firewalls because the
security group is a stateful firewall
and a network acl is a state less viable
and it's really important to understand
the difference
so let's look at an example we have a
client here so this is a computer that
wants to access a service on a web
server and we've got a firewall in the
middle
so what happens is the client is going
to connect to the server the server is a
web server it's listening on port 80.
the source port is the port that's
assigned to the connection by the
computer and it's what's called a high
numbered port it's a port above 1024 and
it's dynamically assigned for every
connection
so we have a source port and a
destination port
and we have a source and destination ip
as well
now the return traffic has a source port
of port 80 because that's where the web
service port runs and the destination
port of 65188 and of course the ips are
switched around as well so the
destination ip will be the client the
source ip will be the web server now
what do we need in the firewall rule
table to allow this to work well what we
need here
is we need a rule for http that allows
the source ip
10.1.1.1
to talk to the destination ip 10.2.1.10
and it has to have the source port and
the destination port specified now of
course this is a dynamically assigned
port so
we don't know what that is ahead of time
so what you'd most likely have here is
any so rather than having this source
port specified we'd have the any
specified so any source port is
acceptable
and then rather than a specific source
ip we might have any because it's an
internet-based connection
so those are things that we can play
around with in our rule tables but the
destination port will always be 80
because that's where the web server runs
and we want to make sure that we don't
allow connections to any port on the web
server
now that's the traffic coming inbound to
the web server what about the return
traffic going back
well in that case things are swapped
around so we've got the same protocol
the source ip of the web server the
destination ip of the client and the
source port of 80 in the destination
port of the dynamic port of the client
now again you'd probably have the
destination port and the destination ip
as any because you want to allow traffic
coming from any client on the internet
if you're running a public web service
but you still might need a rule set for
the outbound traffic and this is where
the difference comes in between state
full and state less firewalls
so a state full firewall will allow the
return traffic automatically
now this is what a security group is
what that means is with a security group
you only need this rule at the top here
you need a rule that says that you're
going to allow the traffic from whatever
client on whatever port but you're going
to allow inbound to port 80 on your web
server
and then the return traffic is
automatically allowed so you don't have
to worry about the return traffic it's
going to just go out automatically it's
going to be allowed because the firewall
is clever enough to know that that's
part of the connection and so it just
allows that return traffic now a state
less viable checks for an allow rule for
both connections now this is what a
network acl does
so with a network acl you need both the
inbound rule and the outbound rule so
you need to make sure that you have the
inbound rule for traffic coming in and
the outbound rule for traffic going back
even if it's the same connection it
doesn't understand that that's part of
the same connection it treats them
separately so really important to
understand those differences when you
configure your network acls now let's
have a look at a security group this is
what a security group rule set looks
like
so here we have separate rules defined
for inbound and outbound traffic what
we're looking at here is the inbound
traffic
now again because it's stateful we don't
have to have a rule for the return
traffic but we still might need an
outbound rule for traffic going out from
our instances so when our instances that
are attached to the security group are
initiating connections outbound
so here we can see we have several rules
using different protocols and we've got
the protocol specified the port range
and then the source and the source in
many cases might be either an ip address
or ip address range
or it can be a security group id as well
security groups support allow rules only
so there's no such thing as a deny rule
in a security group essentially there's
an implicit deny rule at the end of the
rule set and it's going to check for an
allow and if there is no allow then by
default it's just going to deny the
traffic as i mentioned a security group
can use a source of an ip address an ip
address range or the security group id
of itself or another security group now
let's have a look at a best practice
configuration when using security groups
what we have here
is a public subnet and a private subnet
and we've got an internet facing load
balancer so this is going to distribute
traffic to our web servers so we have a
load balancer we have a web server front
end so this is the one that's actually
users are connecting to from the
internet
and then there's an application layer
that's going to process data and this
could have multiple servers so we have a
load balancer and we need a connections
to be able to come from our clients on
the internet through to the application
layer it might then write to a database
i haven't shown that in this diagram so
let's see how we'd set this up firstly
we create a security group for the
public alb
it allows traffic on port 80 for the web
service from any source on the internet
now outbound it has because it's going
to now create a connection to the web
front end
it has a rule that allows
outbound access to port 80 and we've
specified the actual security group id
public ec2
so that's the name of this security
group so it's only going to allow
traffic outbound to the web front end
the web front end allows traffic only
from the public alb on port 80
and then it has a destination for
outbound traffic of another security
group called private alb and a port of
8080 so that's what that particular
application is listening on the private
alb security group will in turn
only allow inbound traffic from
the public ec2 security group and it
will only allow outbound traffic to the
private ec2
security group and that's the one which
has the application layer in it
so that's a way that we're locking down
access to the different layers of our
application and ensuring that the
application can talk to other components
but nothing else can so that's a best
practice security group configuration
now let's have a look at network acls
one of the first things you'll notice is
we have inbound and outbound rules again
and we have allow and deny rules
so with nacls you can have an explicit
deny that's different to security groups
remember security groups only support
allow rules
rules are processed in order so you can
see that they're numbered so we
typically number our rules and you might
want to say that the next rules that you
add in are 200 and 201 and then 300 and
301 you can work out your own
process for how you assign those numbers
but just remember that they will be
processed in order now the important
fact about that means that once you
actually reach a rule that either allows
or denies traffic the processing stops
there
so if we have an allow rule
at 100 that allows the traffic then even
if you had a deny rule later on in the
rule set for that specific traffic it's
not going to get there it's going to
allow it because it reaches the allow
and processing finishes so you've got to
be very careful with how you set up your
rules the order that you create them in
and just remember that they will be
processed in order and then when an
allow or a deny is reached then that's
the end of the processing it will either
allow or deny the connection so that's
it for the theory in the next lesson
we're going to do some hands-on and set
up our security groups and network acls
hi guys in this lesson we're going to
use security groups and network acls and
we should already have some instances
running from earlier on in this section
so you should have three instances
running two in a public subnet and one
in a private subnet and what we're going
to do is test various configurations of
security groups and network acls now the
first thing i need to do
back in ec2 is go to security groups and
i'm going to create a new security group
so we have the public web now we're
going to create the private app so this
security group is going to be called
private dash app i've given it a
description and let's choose my vpc for
the vpc now what will the rule be here
well i'm actually going to delete the
outbound rules we've already configured
we've given internet access to this
particular instance before
so we were able to download httpd when
we installed the web service
but for now i'm going to take out
outbound rules which means from now on
it won't be able to connect out to the
internet for inbound rules what i want
to do
is use http so let's just scroll down
find http that's the protocol for the
web server and for source what i'm going
to do here is type sg
and i can see
my public web access
so i'm doing the best practice here what
i want to do is make sure that the web
server in our apt air is only ever going
to allow connections that come from the
web servers on the front end the
public-facing web servers in this
security group so let's create that
security group now we need to assign it
to our instance so let's choose
private1b go to actions
security change security groups
and we're going to remove public
web we're going to choose private app
click on add security group and then
click on save great so that should be
set up correctly now the first thing i
want to do though is test the access to
the security group on our front end
so what i'm going to do is go to
security groups choose the public web
security group
and
under inbound rules
i'm going to edit the inbound rules
and what i want to do here is change
from all traffic and again we're going
to choose http only
we're going to remove the any source and
we're going to specify
my ip
so what that will do is it picks up my
ip address and that means that i will be
able to connect over the internet to
this particular web service now i'm
actually using a vpn we're going to
change it in a moment so if you do have
access to a vpn you'll be able to do
this as well otherwise it can be a
little bit difficult unless you have
multiple public ips but i just want to
show you the concept anyway
so let's just save this rule come back
to instances
take the public i p address and in a
browser
let's just hit enter and that looks
great so i get access to this instance
now what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to go in and change my vpn here so
i'm connecting to a different service
and that means i've got a different ip
now so let's just refresh the page
now you can't see anything happening but
if you look up in the top browser bar
here we can see we're trying to connect
and this is what happens with security
groups when you can't connect it kind of
just hangs for quite a while and then
eventually it will time out
so that's definitely working we're not
able to access the instance now
if i come back to security groups and
what i'd rather do
is choose my public web security group
edit inbound rules
and instead i'm going to change this to
any ipv4 because this is a web server so
we want anyone on the internet to be
able to connect so let's just save that
rule and back over here it failed to
connect let's refresh and now we're back
in again
so that's a good configuration now our
web service is allowing only http from
the internet and then it should be able
to forward onto the app service because
of the security group rules we set up
before so let's test that layer now back
in ec2 let's go to instances
and what i want to do here is connect to
my public 1a instance over instance
connect
and i'm going to check the private ip
address of my instance in my private
subnet and that's 104 148. now i've just
noticed one of the things we have done
here we've got two secure so we've
locked ourselves out now if you just
click on this note here it takes you
over to an article and we can see that
we actually need port 22 from our ip
address to be able to access the
instance
so let's go back and set this up as a
secure configuration so going back into
security groups what we need to do is go
to public web edit inbound rules
add a rule
and this one can be ssh and what we'll
do here is we're just going to add any
internet address because i might be
changing my internet address a couple of
times
so otherwise of course you could use my
ip or have a range of addresses that you
trust that would be a more secure
configuration but for now we will be
changing ips so i'm happy to have that
as open so let's save those rules now
let's try and retry this instance
connect and we're in
so the way i want to try and test that
we can connect to our app layer is using
curl dash s and then putting in the ip
104-148
let's hit enter and we get a response so
that's great now remember we didn't have
an outbound rule from that security
group so the response traffic is coming
back purely because this is a stateful
firewall so that's it for security
groups let's move on and have a look at
configuring a network acl back in the
vpc management console let's go to
network acls
and what we'll see is there are already
network acls so we've got one here for
our custom vpc now let's go in and have
a look at the configuration
so we have inbound rules we have a rule
number 100 allowing all traffic inbound
and then at the end we have a deny rule
so remember these get processed in order
so in this case everything gets allowed
because of the allow rule so the deny
rule doesn't get processed
outbound we've got exactly the same
thing so let's try something what i'm
going to do
is edit the inbound rules and i'm going
to add a rule
and i'm going to make this 101 and what
i'm going to do is specify
http
source is going to be my ip address so i
know my ip address is this one at the
moment so i put slash 32 for an exact
match
and i'm going to click on deny so i'm
going to deny
access from this particular ip address
to http now do you think this is going
to work hopefully you realize there's an
error here but let's just save the
changes
and we'll go and check it out back in
ec2 i'm just going to copy the public ip
of my instance go to a new web page hit
enter and i get access so of course that
didn't work now let's go and see why
back in the vpc management console let's
edit these rules for the network acl now
as you know rules get processed in order
so we've got a deny rule here that's
after and allow with the allow allows
everything so actually this is not going
to work
let's change this to 99
sort by rule order
and now we have a specific deny before
an allow
so essentially it's going to look
through the rule set it's going to see
that traffic's coming in on port 80 from
this particular ip and it's going to
deny it
so we never get to the allow rule for
this particular traffic
so let's save changes
so we'll go and test this out now but
there's just one thing that you need to
understand with security group rules
when you apply them they do actually get
put into effect
pretty much immediately there can be a
bit more of a delay with a network acl
so if you find you still have access to
your instance then it's probably just
because you're a bit too fast so just
give it a couple of minutes and try
again and we should find that we do get
denied in a browser window here let's
paste in our ip address and sure enough
it looks like it's hanging
so that's clearly not working
now what if i change my ip so this time
i can change to somewhere different
and very quickly this time the
connection did actually change and it
did allow me in
so sometimes the network acl rules apply
super fast and sometimes there's a bit
of a delay so it really can vary
so that shows you how to use a deny rule
with a network acl now i'm just going to
come back in and clean up that rule so i
don't want to have any deny rules in my
network acl so let's just remove that
one out from the inbound rules and save
changes now there are a couple of things
we can clean up now to make sure that we
don't get any bills
firstly let's go to our nat gateway
these can cost money so let's just
delete this nat gateway
and that's gone and don't forget you
will also need to make sure that the
elastic ip has also been removed from
your account back in ec2 now i do want
to keep one public and one private
instance but i can terminate the other
public instance now we will actually use
the command line for this i just want to
show you another cli command back in our
file here we can specify the values
for our ec2 instances so i've just got
one here so i'm going to put it in
inverted commas
copy this command and back in my command
line let's just try and terminate this
instance and when you do that you'll see
that the current state is shutting down
and the previous state was running so we
now know that our ec2 instance is being
terminated so that's it for now but do
leave those other two instances running
because we will be using them in
subsequent lessons
hello and welcome to this lesson
there are quite a few circumstances
where we might want to be able to
connect machines that we're running in
different vpcs together
using ipv4 or ipb6
so for instance we might have two vpcs
which could be in the same region they
could be in a different region or even a
different account
and we want the ec2 instances in those
two vpcs to be able to communicate using
private ipv4 addresses or maybe ipv6
addresses
now a way that we can do that is to use
vpc peering
vpc pairing allows routing for those
addresses internally between those vpcs
when i say internally what i mean is
it's not going out to the internet it's
using the aws global network to route
traffic between the vpc so it never
touches the internet it does get
encrypted when it moves between regions
and it uses private ipv4 and also ipv6
addresses so it's a great technology for
lots of use cases let's have a look at
how we can use vpc peering
so let's say we have a vpc this is vpca
and then we have another vpc vpcb
and we want to be able to route
connections between these two so we've
got easy2 instances maybe rds databases
even lambda functions anything that
communicates inside a vpc
and we want to be able to connect those
resources together using private ipv4
addresses
so what we can do
is establish a vpc pairing connection
between those two vpcs
so this will enable routing using
private ipv4 addresses or ipv6 addresses
now the cider blocks for our vpcs must
not overlap
so this is a very important
consideration when you're choosing the
cider blocks to use for your vpcs
because even if they're in different
accounts you might someday want to
connect your vpcs together and if they
have the same cider blocks or cider
blocks to overlap with each other then
that won't work
so you must have cider blocks that don't
overlap
now what if we have another vpc vpcc
and vpcd a fourth one so they all have
their own cider blocks so looks good we
can definitely set up vpc peering
between these
so what we do we establish a vpc pairing
connection between bbc a and vpcc
between vpc b and vpcd
and then with vpcc and vpcd
so we now have four peering connections
set up
but the problem with vpc peering is it
doesn't support transitive peering now
what that means is let's say we have
resources in vpc a and it has appearing
connection with vpcb
vpcb then has appearing connection with
vpcd
so does that mean that vpca can
communicate with resources in vpc d
by going via the vpcb well no it doesn't
work transitive routing doesn't work so
what we actually have to do is set up
two more peering connections
we've now got appearing connection
between a and d
and between b and c
so we've got a full mesh topology
because vpc peering doesn't support
transitive relationships we do need this
full mesh so that becomes quite a lot of
connections now with these four vpcs
it's not too bad but you can imagine if
you spread this out across a lot more
vpcs soon this full mesh topology means
you've got a huge number of connections
to set up and to manage so it becomes a
bit unwieldy and there are other
solutions which we're going to look at
later on in this section and in sections
to come
now as i mentioned before the vpcs can
be in different accounts and they can be
in different regions as well now let's
have a look in a bit more detail about
how we set this up so we've got region
one
and we've got region two
so in this example we've got two vpcs in
different regions could be in the same
account or different accounts and we
want to pair them together now they each
have their own cider blocks which are
unique they're not overlapping so that's
good
and then we've got some subnets now
these could be private or public subnets
because remember it's the private
addresses of the instances that will be
used for the vpc to vpc communication
and we've got some instances running in
these subnets now i'm showing public
because we're going to set up a lab very
much like this it makes it easier for us
to connect to our ec2 instances if
they're in public subnets
so we create a vpc peering connection
and i'll show you how to do this in the
console
now the next thing we need to do is set
up our security groups so let's say we
want to use the icmp protocol to send a
ping request from one instance to
another and the other instance back
again
well in that case we have to set up our
security group rules as well
and we can use the sider of the other
region
so we can use the cider block as the
source and say that anything coming from
that cider block is going to be allowed
based on this rule now another thing we
have to set up for this to work is the
route tables and what we do is we have a
destination route which goes to the
cider block of the remote vpc
and we specify the peering id so when we
set up the peering connection we'll have
a peering id and we're going to specify
that as a target and then we do the
reverse on the other side so that the
route table will send any traffic
destined for this side of block to the
peering connection and then it gets
routed across to the correct vpc
hi guys in this lesson we're going to
create a vpc peering connection between
two vpcs in two different accounts
so the configuration is going to be
pretty much what we see on the screen
here we have our management account in
our aws organization and our production
account and we're going to have a vpc in
each using these cider blocks
and then we're going to create security
groups
and we're going to specify these
particular rules now firstly let's have
a look at how we establish the
connection
we need to establish a peering
connection between the vpcs and we can
do that in the console
then we need to update the route table
really important that you have a route
to your target so the route table for
this vpc
must specify as a destination the cider
block of the other vpc and the peering
target and then the reverse is true over
on the right hand side our security
group rules will ensure we can use ssh
and icmp to connect and the way we'll
test the connectivity is to ping from
one instance to the other using the
private ip address and that will show us
that we're using the vpc peering
connection and not the internet now
there is a bit of background work you
need to do before we get started so
unless you want to use the default vpc
in your production account you should
create a new vpc using the same ranges i
just showed you
so from the vpc management console
you're going to want to change to dct
production go to your vpcs and then
create a vpc now i've already created
mine and i have the values for you in a
file
so just open the code amazon vpc custom
vpc prod file and this is the
information you need now you know how to
do this you've done it earlier on in
this section so just create this vpc
and add these subnets add your internet
gateway your private route table and
then we're good to go now we don't need
all of this for this particular exercise
but let's just create it standard as per
the vpc in our management account and
then we might use some of these subnets
later on so let's get started now i need
a couple of pieces of information with
my vpc selected in my prod account i'm
going to
copy this owner id that's the account id
and i'm going to put that into my file
next i need the vpc id and let's put
that in the file now we're going to
switch back to the management account
let's go to peering connections create
pairing connection
we need to give it a name let's just
call it my peer
select the local vpc which is myvpc
we can choose another account rather
than my account and copy this account id
we'll paste that in
we're going to stick to the same region
but we need the
id on the other end as well so that's
the one that we copied here so let's
copy that to our clipboards
paste that in
and create the peering connection so it
says here a vpc peering connection pcx
and then it's got a number
my peer has been requested the owner of
the remote vpc must accept the peering
connection so let's go back and do that
let's go to dct production go to peering
connections
and we can see the request pending
acceptance so just select it on the left
and then go to actions accept request
and we can accept that one and that's
done
now one of the things we're going to
need to test is going to be an ec2
instance so let's launch an ec2 instance
but before we actually launch that one
i'm going to create the security group
the security group is going to be called
vpc pair dash prod and these are the
rules we're going to set up
so let's create a security group give it
a name i'll just put that in the
description as well
choose the correct vpc
and the outbound rule is fine for now
all we need is the inbound rules to be
set up the first rule i'm going to set
up is icmp ipv4 so all icmp that's going
to allow ping requests and it's going to
come from 10.0.0.0.16.
the next rule is ssh you can either do
custom tcp and put in the port range or
choose ssh and it will do it for you
and same as the one above we just want
to give it the same
addresses
so this should allow inbound connections
from the vpc in the other account in the
management account using from any ip
address in the entire cider block
so we can save this security group now
let's launch an instance that uses that
security group
so i'm going to launch an instance
it's going to be linux 2 ami
t2 micro
make sure you select your vpc
i'm going to put it into my public
subnet public 1a let's click on next
go through to security group
and we're going to select a security
group
and that's going to be vpc peer prod
click on review and launch and launch
if you don't have a key pair for this
region which i don't at this stage then
i'm going to create a new one i've
called it prod dash nv
i'll download that key pair and then
launch my instance
so now let's go back in the ec2
management console to the management
account in the management account we
need to set up this security group and
we're going to assign that to one of our
instances in a public subnet so in this
account we've got two instances running
let's go to security groups create a
security group it's called vpc pair dash
mgmt i'll put the same in the
description
select the correct vpc and then let's
add the same rules as before this time
the block is going to be 10.1.0.0.16
so now we have the same protocol
specified so we should be able to
connect from the prod vpc to the
management vpc using these protocols as
well
so let's create that security group go
back to instances public 1a
actions security
change security groups and we're going
to add in vpc pair
mgmt and the reason i'm not going to
remove public web is because we have a
rule in there allowing access from the
internet to port 22 which we need for
instance connect
so with those two added let's save the
security group configuration and the
very last thing that we don't want to
forget is our route tables so let's go
and do that now back in the vpc console
for my management account i'm going to
go to my main route table
choose routes
edit
add this one's going to be 10.1.0.08
16. and it's going to go over a peering
connection we've only got one of those
and it's called my peer so let's save
that
switch across to the dct production
account
we need to choose the main route table i
didn't label this one let's do it now
but i can see that it's attached to my
vpc
so let's go to routes edit routes add
and this one should be for 10.0.0.0
16.
and again we're going to specify peering
connection
it's going to see the same peering
connection and we can save changes so
that's it hopefully it's all set up now
we've updated our route tables
we've got these two security groups with
rules so that we should be able to use
these protocols
based on our private ip addresses so
that's that's the real test here is to
use private ip addresses to see if we
can connect we can definitely ping via
the public ips if we got our security
group rules set up correctly
but we want to do it via private ips
because that shows that rather than
going out to an internet gateway we're
sticking within the private space across
the peering connection back in ec2 let's
select the instance id and we want to
copy the private ip address i'm going to
just put that into my file here and
coming back here let's switch to the
management account
choose the public 1a instance connect
by instance connect and let me just try
and remember this ip1011221
so let's ping
10.1.1.221
and hit enter and there we go we get a
response that's across accounts and it's
also across regions and it shows we've
got this bi-directional traffic going
between these two vpcs the other
protocol we enabled was ssh
so let's just make sure that we can
create an ssh connection
10.1.1.221
and we can now i'm not actually going to
log in because i would need my key pair
and i need to specify some more details
as well but i just want to see that the
port is open and that shows that the
security groups are set up correctly as
well as the underlying networking to
allow this traffic over private ip
addresses so that's really it for this
lesson now the only other thing you
might want to do is you could practice
by doing the same thing and extending
this configuration through to your
instance in your private subnet use your
public subnet instance as a bastion host
you might have to use agent forwarding
and then make sure you can connect
bi-directionally from there as well so
that's just an additional bit of fun
that you might want to have if you want
to practice a bit more so now that we've
finished with this lab we can actually
terminate our instance in the private
subnet we didn't use that in this lab
unless you carried on with the
configuration but we will leave the
public instance running for now so let's
terminate this instance and then you
should go over to your production
environment as well and terminate your
ec2 instance there and then we're all
cleaned up
you'll remember that earlier in the
course i talked about how some aws
services are private in that they run
within a vpc like ec2
whereas other services are public
because they have a public endpoint like
amazon s3 for example
so that means when you connect to amazon
s3 you use a public dns name to connect
to it that's a public endpoint
now what if you wanted to connect an
instance to amazon s3 but you didn't
want to use the public internet it might
be an instance in a private subnet well
that's where vpc endpoints come in
there's a few use cases for vpc
endpoints with connecting privately to
s3 being one of them and there are two
different types there's a vpc interface
endpoint and a vpc gateway endpoint the
gateway endpoint is one which we could
use for s3 and the interface endpoint is
slightly different and is used for other
services so let's start there first
let's look at an example using a vpc
interface endpoint so we've got ec2
running in a private subnet and we don't
want this instance to have a public ip
and we don't want it to be routed out to
the internet via a nat gateway
so we provision an interface endpoint
which creates an eni in the subnet
and then the instance can connect via
that eni to public services but it's
using private ip addresses to connect to
them
now each interface endpoint can connect
to one of many aws services
and you can connect to an aws private
link powered service as well we'll look
at that shortly to see what that means
so this is a way that we can connect our
ec2 instances to these services using
private ip addresses
now let's look at the difference between
that and a gateway endpoint
so in this case i want to connect to
amazon s3 to store data in an s3 bucket
and again i don't want to have a public
ip address so an instance in a public
subnet in this case it is in a private
subnet and i don't want a provision in
that gateway or at least i don't want
this traffic to go out to the internet
so i could provision a s3 gateway
endpoint this is slightly different it
uses a route table entry so we now have
to put a route table entry to point our
traffic to the s3 gateway endpoint and
that uses the prefix list for the s3 and
the gateway id the instance again
connects using a private ip address to
the gateway endpoint and then from there
it connects to amazon s3 now you can
secure this with i am policies so you
can apply a policy to the endpoint and
you can also apply bucket policies so
for example you can have a bucket policy
that limits access to
any traffic that's coming from the
gateway endpoint
so you now have a bucket which will only
accept traffic from instances that are
using the s3 gateway endpoint so let's
just recap the differences with the
interface endpoint you've got an elastic
network interface with a private ip with
a gateway endpoint you have a target in
your route table for the gateway so
interface endpoints will use dns entries
to redirect traffic whereas gateway
endpoints use the prefix list in the
route table to redirect traffic
now what services well there's quite a
few with an interface endpoint api
gateway cloud formation and cloudwatch
are just a few examples lots of the
public services can be accessed via an
interface endpoint but a gateway
endpoint is restricted to amazon s3 and
dynamodb only with an interface endpoint
you use security groups to control
traffic whereas with a gateway endpoint
you can use vpc endpoint policies
now lastly let's look at how we can use
this in a service provider model so what
i mean is we have a consumer vpc
and a service provider vpc
so we've got a couple of subnets in each
vpc
and what's happening is the service
provider is creating a service and that
service is behind a network load
balancer
and they want to provide that service to
consumers
so what happens as a consumer is you
provision an endpoint and then you use
that endpoint to access the service
so we're actually publishing a service
in one side and then we're consuming it
in the vpc on the left and using an
interface endpoint to actually consume
that service
so that's how it works and in the next
lesson we're going to set up a gateway
endpoint
welcome to another hands-on in this
lesson we're going to create a vpc
endpoint it's going to be a gateway
endpoint and we're going to use some
policies to see how we can control
access to an amazon s3 bucket
so this is basically the configuration
we already have a vpc and a public
subnet and we've got an instance running
in it from earlier on
now we're going to create an amazon s3
bucket i'm getting ahead of myself a
little bit here because we actually
cover s3 in a lot of detail in the next
section if you're completely unfamiliar
with it and you want to get a primer you
could flick forward but we won't be
doing too much here it's going to be
fairly straightforward stuff now when we
create our endpoint a route will be
added to our route table and that will
point to a destination which will
resolve to the ip addresses of amazon s3
now what happens is this is a more
specific route than any other route like
the route going out to the internet so
it should follow this path which means
any connections that go to
the aws s3 endpoints should be routed
via the gateway endpoint and we'll be
able to prove that that's happening and
that we're not using the public internet
so we will modify the policy here to do
that you'll see what i mean shortly and
on the s3 bucket will add a policy now
bucket policies are basically just
resource based policies it uses json
language just like we do with iam
policies but we just use them to control
access to our buckets so we apply them
directly to the buckets rather than to a
principle like an identity based policy
the first thing to do is to head over
and create the vpc endpoint
i'm in my management account in north
virginia
on the left here under endpoints
we can create an endpoint
let's click this button create endpoint
and under services if we put in s3 and
search
we get these options we're going to
choose gateway for amazon s3
now we need to specify which route table
to actually update now as you can see
the route table for rvpc the custom one
is not there that's because we need to
make sure we specify our custom vpc
now we can see our route tables and i'm
going to choose the one that's the main
route table
so that's the one associated with my
public subnets
now the policy by default is full access
so we have a statement here that's
action any action star
effect allow and then any resource and
any principle
so it's very open but you can customize
that so let's just create the end point
and it's being created for us
so here is our endpoint now what we want
to do is go to route tables and just
make sure that the route table has been
updated so that's this one here the main
route table for our custom vpc under
routes we can now see that we have the
destination
and this is going via a vpc endpoint so
that's the route to amazon s3 going via
the endpoint
so that's set up correctly
another thing we need to do we're going
to run some commands against amazon s3
from our ec2 instance so i need to give
it some privileges i'm going to create a
role
so let's choose create role here in the
iam service
common use cases is going to be ec2 so
we're going to allow ec2 to call an aws
service for permissions
just type in s3 and search and we're
going to give full access
i'm going to copy the name of this
policy
and we're going to use that for the role
name as well
so let's just paste that in
create the role
and now we have a role that we can
assign to our ec2 instance
so over in ec2 let's choose our instance
go to actions
security modify i am role
and we're going to choose a role and we
should see it in here and there it is
amazon s3 full access
so let's save
and our instance now has the privileges
it needs
over in the amazon s3 console which you
can find under services and storage
we're going to create an s3 bucket so a
bucket is just a container into which we
add objects objects of files and videos
or whatever you want to add
i'm going to call mine dct vpce test and
it's going to be in north virginia i can
scroll down don't need to change
anything else at this point
and create this bucket
so now that we have a bucket we can add
some objects objects as i say are just
files this is an object-based storage
system so we can come in and add files
i'm just going to add a couple of jpeg
images
and upload
so simple as that we have some files on
amazon s3
now let's come back to ec2 choose our
public 1a instance
go to instance connect
and connect
now we haven't specified any policies
yet but let's just check that we can
connect to amazon s3
so now we should be able to run commands
against s3 let's try running aws
s3
ls
and hit enter
and we can see our buckets we should be
able to run aws
s3
ls
and then s3 colon slash and our bucket
name as well and if we hit enter here we
should see the contents of the bucket so
at the moment everything is working
great now how do we know this is going
over the end point rather than going
over the internet because we are in a
public subnet
well let's go back to our endpoint
with my endpoint selected i'm going to
choose policy i'm going to copy this
code here in the endpoint policy
choose custom
paste it in
and let's just change the policy to deny
so this should deny everything
now if we're going by the internet this
shouldn't make any difference
but if we're going via the end point
then this should block access
so back in our instance let's try and
rerun that command
and we get an access denied let's try
and run the ls command again we get an
access denied so it's definitely not
working
back in my endpoint i'm just going to
change this back again because i don't
really want that to deny me from access
at this point so let's just go back to
full access click on save
the next thing we're going to do is set
up our bucket policy and the bucket
policy is going to prevent any access
except from
the vpc endpoint
and that's something that comes up in a
lot of exam scenarios so let's go into
our bucket here
go to permissions
come down to
bucket policy click edit
and i'm going to copy the bucket arn
now this is the bucket policy so it's in
your code amazon vpc directory bucket
policy bpce
what you need to do is take this whole
arn here and just paste
your correct arn over the top for your
bucket
and there's two options here one is
without the slash star and one is with
so the one with the slash star means
that you can also
look at the objects within the bucket
now the last thing we need here is the
vpce id
so back at my endpoint here i'm going to
copy the endpoint id
and then come back and paste that into
my policy
so that's it this policy should now
apply now what does it do let's have a
look the policy is a deny so it's going
to deny
any principle
any s free action
on these resources specifically
if the condition does not equal
this vpc endpoint id so in other words
if you're not coming from this vpc
endpoint id you're going to get denied
if you are coming from this vpc endpoint
id it doesn't apply
so let's copy
all of this code to our clipboards
and back in the bucket policy editor
here i'm going to paste it all in
and just save these changes so let's go
back and make sure we haven't broken
access
back in our instance let's try them to
run the aws h3 ls command and we see our
buckets let's check that we can see
inside our bucket and that works
correctly now that's good because this
instance is coming from the vpc endpoint
so again we've proven we're coming via
the endpoint
but the other thing we can do is check
from our own computers and we shouldn't
be allowed access
so back in the terminal here i'm going
to run aws s3 ls
and i do see the buckets
but what about if i try to see inside
the bucket
so the full command is aws s3 ls s3
colon
slash and then your bucket name and hit
enter
so i've got an access is denied so that
proves that i'm not able to access the
bucket from my computer because i'm not
coming via the endpoint now let's just
go back to the console and have a look
at the bucket in the bucket here you can
see that we no longer have permissions
to this bucket we've actually locked
ourselves out because i'm actually
coming through the console here and the
console doesn't come by the endpoint
so what we need to do is go back to our
ec2 instance
now that is it for this lesson we have
finished with the ec2 instance and the
vpc endpoint
with the endpoint you can simply select
the endpoint go to actions and then
delete endpoint and that should clean up
the entry in your route table as well
but you can always just go
and check you might need to refresh the
page
and then it has gone so once you've done
that terminate your instance and we've
finished for this lesson
hi guys welcome to this lesson this
lesson is about the aws client vpn
so it is exactly what it sounds like
this is a way that you can connect your
client computer to the aws data center
to a vpc
via a vpn connection so a virtual
private network connection so let's say
you've got a computer which is windows
or mac or linux
you're able to set up a client
connection from there into a vpc and
that means you're then able to
communicate with resources in that vpc
so you might be able to connect to an
ec2 instance directly using private ip
addresses now of course it's a virtual
private network so that does mean that
it's encrypted as well end to end
so let's look at how you set them up so
here we have a region in that region we
have a vpc with a couple of subnets
now we create a vpn endpoint
and the vpn endpoint is associated with
subnets so the client vpn network
interfaces are created in the subnet
and that is the method by which the vpn
connection is then able to communicate
with resources in the subnets because
there is an association between this
network adapter that's provisioned into
the subnet and the vpn endpoint we then
have the client computer and that's
going to be running some vpn software
the vpn software is not aws software so
you need to choose one of the available
options there's lots of free options in
the hands-on in the next lesson we're
going to use openvpn the client software
will establish a connection with the vpn
endpoint over ssl tls so port 443 and
that's going to be via the internet the
vpn endpoint will actually perform
source network address translation
from the side block that's associated
with the vpn client to the cider block
that's associated with the vpc
and on the client side if you look in
your route table you can run a command
on windows which is route print
and you would then see your route table
and you'd be able to see that you have a
destination for the cider block of the
vpc and a gateway which is pointing
at the vpn endpoint so that's the theory
behind how a client vpn works again this
is an encrypted connection over the
internet from your computer so your
computer is then able to communicate
using private ip addresses
over to your instances in your subnets
within your vpc so that's how it all
works and in the next lesson we're going
to set this up using a windows client on
amazon workspaces and a vpn endpoint
hi guys the other type of vpn that we
can establish in aws is a site-to-site
vpn so a site-to-site vpn is where you
might connect for instance a customer
data center or office location into aws
and have a private network established
over the internet so an encrypted
connection which you can then tunnel
through your traffic and again use
internal ip addresses private ip
addresses
so the setup looks something like this
we've got an aws vpc on the left and
then on the right hand side we've got a
corporate data center that could be a
data center or an office and you want to
connect that into aws
so aws vpn is a managed ipsec vpn
and what we do is we create something
called a virtual private gateway which
is also known as vgw
on the aws side
the vgw is deployed on the aws and then
a customer gateway is deployed on the
customer side when you have those two
components you can then establish a
encrypted vpn connection over the
internet the vpn connection supports
either static routes or bgp peering and
routing so in our route tables we can
actually specify a destination
for the cider block of the corporate
data center and then point it to a
virtual gateway id so that's this device
here so that means any traffic going to
this ip range will be sent over the vpn
connection so it's fairly
straightforward and the most common use
case for this is what we see here it's
connecting in data centers or office
locations to aws so that you can then
tunnel your traffic over an encrypted
connection using the internet it can
also be used sometimes as a backup
connection for direct connect and we'll
look at that later on in this section
that's all the theory i wanted to cover
for now and what we'll do in the next
lesson is it's going to be practical
we're going to do a hands-on lab where
we're going to set up a vpn connection
aws vpn cloud hub is not actually a
service that you can go and find in the
aws console what this really is
is a pattern an architectural pattern
that you can use when you utilize the
aws site-to-site vpn technology so let's
have a look at the architecture in which
you can implement cloudhub
so we've got a vpc
and we've implemented a virtual private
gateway at vgw
and that's obviously deployed on the aws
site
we then have multiple customer offices
or these could be customer data centers
but they're different on-premises
environments that we want to connect
using a virtual private network to aws
now the way that we connect them in a
cloud hub topology is using a hub and
spoke model so in other words aws is the
hub the vpc
and then the spokes go out to each of
these offices
so what we do is we deploy a customer
gateway into each of these offices each
of these customer gateways has a unique
bgp asn that's a border gateway protocol
autonomous system number so bgp is a
protocol that you can use for
advertising routes to different parts of
your network
and each environment has its own
asn and that corresponds with the routes
that would be advertised into the
network so the ip prefixes
so you must have a unique bgp asn for
each office and then we can establish a
vpn connection between each of those
customer gateways and the same virtual
gateway on the aws side now network
traffic can originate from an office and
go to the vpc or the vpc back to an
office
but also it can go between the customer
offices or the customer on premises
environments whether they're offices or
data centers
so the customer office here can
communicate
via the vgw to this customer office here
so we're using the aws site to site vpn
to establish a routing topology which
connects multiple customer offices as
well as the vpc itself now this is using
ipsec vpn's the same vpns as we just
looked at in previous lessons so that's
it that's vpncloudhub as i mentioned if
you go around looking in the aws console
you won't find cloudhub but if you
actually do a search online you'll find
some articles about this architecture
which can give you a bit more insight as
to how it's set up but basically we're
just connecting multiple customer
gateways to a single virtual private
gateway and then it's up to you to
configure your bgp protocol accordingly
to advertise the routes that you want to
advertise into the network so that's it
for a quick overview of cloudhub i'll
see you in the next lesson
we've already talked about virtual
private network connections vpns now
vpns typically run over the public
internet and that means that we are
subject to the bandwidth constraints and
the potential latency issues on the
internet we can't control the internet
we don't know from minute to minute hour
to hour what's going to happen we can
get a good service provider but still
sometimes there's a long way between us
and our services on aws and that means
somewhere along that path we could have
congestion or latency
so one of the solutions to that is using
direct connect or dx
dx means that you have a private
connection into aws that means it's not
shared it's not public it's dedicated to
you it's a connection all the way into
your aws data center and into your
amazon vpc
so let's have a look at how we set this
up so let's say we have a vpc with a
couple of subnets and then we've got our
corporate data center or it could be
your office
now in the middle here is something
called a direct connect location these
are different to aws regions and there's
lots of these around the world so there
could well be direct connect locations
in the data center where your equipment
is or somewhere nearby in your city
in the direct connect location
aws have a cage so they have a rack full
of their own equipment and then there's
the customer or partner cage so either
you have a rack with some equipment in
that data center or you leverage an aws
partner
now both of these cages will have a
router so we've got the direct connect
endpoint on the aws
cage and then in the customer or partner
cage we have the customer or partner
router
and you must use certain types of
connectors a dx port is actually
allocated for you
and then what you do is cross-connect
between the customer or partner router
and aws
we then have a customer router actually
in your data center and direct connect
in aws
and we can form the direct connect
connection
so now
from your customer router you need to
have a physical connection
into the customer or partner cage so
that might be something you need to
speak to your local isp to get that
connection from this point into your
data center unless you happen to have
all your equipment in a direct connect
location which can often be the case
then from there we have the cross
connect into aws
and then a physical connection all the
way in to
an aws region where your vpc is that's a
physical fiber connection
running at either one or 10 gigabits per
second now 100 gig has just been
released recently for some locations
if you want slower speeds you can talk
to a partner and they can give you
speeds from 50 megabits per second
upwards
so let's have a look at some of the
benefits you've got private connectivity
between aws and your data center or
office
you get a consistent network experience
you can control the network path here
it's not like on the internet where you
just don't know what's happening
that means you can increase the speed
improve latency get better bandwidth and
throughput through your connection
dx can be quite expensive for many
customers but for those who transfer a
lot of data from their data center into
aws it can be cost effective
now let's go a level deeper
so we've got the same configuration here
and you can see some of the aws services
that are in the public space at the
bottom of this box here
so how do we provision connectivity
across this private line
well we have to create something called
a private vif a vif is a virtual
interface a private vif is the way that
you connect into your vpc in the same
region
using a virtual gateway so there's a
virtual private gateway
attached to your vpc and the private vif
will send data across the dx connection
into your vpc
aviv is a virtual interface that uses
802.1 q virtual local area networks
vlans and a bgp session as well now what
about connecting to the public space you
don't connect to the public aws services
via a private vif
instead you need a public vif
a public vif will allow you to connect
to aws services in the public space that
are in any aws region
but you can't connect to the internet
via the public cliff
now what if you want to connect to
multiple vpcs in the same region
well in that case you have multiple
virtual private gateways and multiple
private vifs to connect to each vpc you
can also create something called a
hosted vif which means you can share a
vif with another aws account as well as
i mentioned a bit earlier you can get
lower speeds from apn partners so these
are partners in the aws partner network
and those speeds can then be from 50 to
500 megabits per second
100 gig is also featuring in some select
locations those are the aws direct
connect locations
so that could be where you are might not
be probably won't be on the exam yet
it's very very new something that is
really important for the exam is to
remember that dx connections are not
encrypted you cannot encrypt a dx
connection so there's no way that you
can select a check box and enable
encryption in transit it just isn't a
feature
so what do you do if you want to encrypt
your traffic
well you can then create an ipsec
site-to-site vpn over the top of the
connection so you have your dx
connection
and you're basically running a vpn over
that connection so now your traffic is
private it's on your private dx
connection you've got the latency and
bandwidth features and you're also
encrypting your traffic as well using a
vpn tunnel
so that's really important to remember
it does come up in a lot of exam
questions now that's it for the core
theory around direct connect and in the
next lesson we're going to look at
another feature called direct connect
gateway
welcome to this lesson in this lesson
i'm going to cover aws direct connect
gateway now the best way to understand
the benefits of direct connect gateway
is to have a look at an architecture
where we don't use it and how complex it
can get
and then we're going to look at when we
use direct connect gateway and how it
can solve some problems
so here's an example architecture where
we're not using direct connect gateway
now we have multiple regions and we have
an office and we have multiple dx
locations in different parts of the
world
and what we're doing is we're connecting
each of those regions to a dx location
that's close to that region and then
into a corporate office
and we're doing the same
in the eu central one region at the
bottom here as we are in us west one so
this company now has multiple locations
where they then have connections into
aws using dx you then must establish a
private vif and that connects to a
single vpc in the same region using a
virtual gateway
we do the same in the second region
now dx is a regional service so
obviously multiple dx locations have to
be used for this topology
and also requires regional offices or
long distance expensive links
so in other words these customer routers
here have to either be in one low
physical location one geographic
location and you've got a very long
distance link coming from
europe or the us or these are multiple
offices in different geographical areas
so when we want to start connecting our
offices to multiple regions using direct
connect it can become quite expensive
and quite complex
so now let's look at an architecture
where we use direct connect gateway so
in this case we have the same two
regions we have a single corporate
office and a single dx location and so
we now only have that connection into
our office from one location and we have
a dx gateway
and then the dx gateway
is actually connecting two multiple
regions
a private vif is associated with the dx
gateway
and then
the dx gateway is associated with a
virtual gateway in each of the regions
bgp advertises a route to all vpcs via
the dx gateway and the traffic that's
going from the dx gateway to these
different regions is going over the aws
back burn so it's using that consistent
network experience of the aws global
network
now network traffic can go from the
office to either region so any of the
vpc is connected and of course i'm only
showing two here but you can have many
many regions that are connected to a dx
gateway
now what you can't do is actually
route regional traffic from one region
to another via the dx gateway it doesn't
support that but you can use it to
connect from your corporate office using
a single dx connection into multiple
regions around the world so that's dx
gateway it's a really useful top
technology if you're a global company
but you don't have global offices or you
want a single office location to have
this consistent network experience into
multiple regions around the world then
this is a great technology to use
aws transit gateway is a really awesome
service it's described by aws as being a
cloud router and it connects vpcs and
on-premises locations together using a
central hub
so let's have a look at what this means
now again what i want to do is show you
a fully meshed architecture without aws
transit gateway to help you understand
the problem we're trying to solve
because when we have lots of vpcs and
on-premises locations it can get really
complex the peering connections that we
set up if we use vpc peering can become
extremely complex
so let's say we have vpc a b c and d
again and we've established our vpc
peering links and as you know there's
going to be quite a few peering links
here we've got six pairing links that
we've got to set up just for four vpcs
and as you increase the number of vpcs
it gets very complex
so here we have six vpc peering
connections we then have a corporate
office connected via a customer gateway
so how do we connect the corporate
office using a site-to-site vpn to each
of these vpcs
well we need a virtual gateway in each
vpc
then we need to establish a connection
to the customer gateway from each vpc
and each of those is its own encrypted
ipsec vpn
so there's four site-to-site vpn
connections and that's not even
including redundancy if you wanted to
add redundancy you'd need another
customer gateway and double the amount
of s2s vpn connections so it starts
getting super complex
let's now look at the same architecture
but with transit gateway in this case
the same four vpcs and a corporate
office we stick transit gateway in the
middle and it becomes the network
transit hub that interconnects the vpcs
and on-premises networks
so now
we have connections into
each of these vpcs the vpc's become
attached to the transit gateway
and you specify one subnet from each
availability zone and that enables
routing within that availability zone
for any other subnets
we then have the customer data center
we've got the corporate office here with
a customer gateway and the customer
gateway connects in
and that's it this is now a service
which is allowing us to connect through
this cloud router this central hub to
any of these vpcs tgws can be attached
to vpns direct connect gateways
third-party appliances and also transit
gateways in other regions and also other
accounts so let's have a look at how it
works with a dx gateway so in this case
rather than using a site-to-site vpn our
corporate office has a customer router
and we're connecting into a dx location
and we're using a dx gateway
so now the dx gateway has a connection
to transit gateway and that's called an
association
we then have the physical connection
back to the corporate office from direct
connect
and we create something called a transit
vehicle this is another type of virtual
interface specifically used for direct
connect gateways when they're associated
to a transit gateway so transit vif is
only used when you're attaching a dx
gateway to a transit gateway
now this architecture then supports full
transitive routing between on-premises
the transit gateway and all of those
connected vpcs as you can imagine when
your company gets bigger and starts
using more vpcs in more regions and you
want to have that transitive peering
between them it can get so complex that
transit gateway will really solve a lot
of challenges so that's it for this
lesson i will see you in the next lesson
hello and welcome to this lesson i'm now
going to talk about using the ipv6
protocol in an amazon vpc so remember i
mentioned earlier in the course that
there's two
versions of ip which are used
extensively one of them is ipv4 that's
by far the most commonly used it's been
around for quite a long time and then
there's ipv6 now ipv6 has also been
around quite a few years but it's not
been used anywhere near as extensively
but that needs to change over time
because we are running short of ipv4
addresses so we're going to have a look
at how you can use ipv6 in a vpc
so let's start by looking at the
structure of the ipv4 address so you
remember it's made up of four numbers
separated by dots and those numbers come
from an octet so that's eight binary
bits which are either one or zero so an
ipv4 address is 32 bits long now let's
have a look at how many addresses you
get for that you get 4.3 billion
addresses which sounds like a big number
and it's a big number if it's dollars in
your bank account but when it's
addresses that need to be assigned to
all sorts of different devices all over
the world in a world full of 7 billion
people it's just not way anywhere near
enough and it might have sounded like
more than enough quite a few years ago
but it became apparent even in the 90s
that it was not going to suffice and it
hasn't
so we are close to exhausting these
addresses and nat has to be used
extensively
so if you're in a company and your
company has thousands of computers
internally then those computers will
most likely be using ipv4 addresses and
those will be private addresses and when
they access the internet they go for a
nat device of some sort and that means
that a public ip address is used to
represent many many pcs so that's a
workaround that we have to put in place
with ipv4
with ipv6 we don't have to worry about
that so let's look at the structure of
an ipv6 address
so this is the structure of ipv6
it also has a network part and a node
part but it's 128 bits long so it's a
much much bigger number
but also it uses hexadecimal whereas
ipv4
uses dotted decimal so that means
there's a lot more potential values that
you can use in hexadecimal versus
decimal so that means the amount of
addresses is much much bigger
and this is the number that's the number
of addresses you can get out of ipv6 and
it's absolutely huge
to put it into some kind of perspective
and by the way if you look on google for
analogies for the size of the ipv6
address space there's all sorts of
fantastic analogies because it really is
massive so one that i like is that you
can get 100 ipv6 addresses for every
atom on earth so that is a huge huge
number which means we never ever have to
worry about running out of ipv6
addresses so let's have a look at how we
need to set up our vpc so we've got a
vpc with a couple of subnets we need to
have an ipv4 cider block and then we
need the individual subnet ranges for
our subnets
now we also need an ipv6 cider block now
so we've allocated one to this account
now aws will assign a slash 56 ipv6
address range to the vpc
then you can create your subnet ranges
within that address space and those
become slash 64 subnets now a 64 subnet
will allow 18 million trillion addresses
so again it's an example of why you
really don't need to worry about how
many addresses you're going to have for
your computers because it's just huge
now you'll notice there's two numbers
highlighted in red at the end of the ip
address here
this is a hexadecimal pair which has
values from 0 0 to ff and this
designates the individual subnet so it
has to be unique for each subnet and it
means that you're going to have a
possible
256 subnets with ipv6 blocks in them and
each of those is a slash 64 so each of
those will support 18 million trillion
addresses so lots of flexibility for
your vpc now let's look at the route
table once we've enabled ipv6 so we now
have a local route for the ipv6 cider
block and we need a route to the
internet gateway for everything that's
outside of that range just like we did
for ipv4 we have the colon colon 0 for
ipv6 pointing at the internet gateway's
id and that means that anything that's
not an ipv6 address in this range will
go to the internet gateway so we'll make
sure that we have that specified in our
route table when we enable ipv6
now all ipv6 addresses are publicly
routable that means there's no network
address translation
now if you want to you can use something
called an egress only internet gateway
now the purpose of this
is when you want to allow outbound
access only using ipv6
so it's kind of like having a ec2
instance in a private subnet with ipv4
and then adding a nat gateway into a
public subnet it means that that
instance is protected from the internet
no one can access it directly from the
internet but it does have internet
access outbound so that's what an egress
only internet gateway does so that's it
for the theory on this topic and in the
next lesson we're going to go in and
enable ipv6 for our vpc
hi guys in this lesson you're going to
learn about vpc flow logs and then we're
also going to set a flow log up to see
how it works and what data actually
captures so vpc flow logs capture
information about the ip traffic going
to and from network interfaces in a vpc
the data is stored using cloudwatch or
amazon s3
and you can create the flow log at
different levels so at the vpc level at
the subnet level or at the interface
level so if it's at the interface level
it's associated with the eni that's
attached to an ec2 instance you can
capture a lot of traffic which is really
useful for troubleshooting purposes and
security as well so let's go and create
a flow log in ec2 i still have an
instance running if you don't have an
instance running just launch an instance
just as we have done before
and
put it into your public 1a subnet and it
should have a public ip address next
we're going to actually send our data to
cloudwatch logs so in the cloudwatch
service i'm going to go to log groups
create log group and create myself a log
group i'm going to call it my subnet
logs
i can set a retention setting for me
let's put five days so after five days i
don't need that data anymore and let's
create the log group next we need to
create a role so the flow log service
has the permissions it needs in the
identity and access management service
we're going to create a role so let's
create a role choose create role we're
going to choose ec2 for now we're going
to modify that soon because that's not
actually the service that's going to be
assuming this role we're going to go
straight past policies because we're
going to add an inline policy
and i'm going to call my role flow logs
cloudwatch i'm going to remove the
description
and create this role now let's find the
role and under permissions we're going
to add an inline policy we're going to
go to json
and we have this json code here in your
code amazon vpc directory and it's vpc
flow logs.json so all you need to do is
copy all of this
as you can see
the service is going to be provided with
the permissions to create a log group
create a log stream put log events
describe blog groups and describe log
streams
so with that copied
let's come back
override all of that code
click on review give it a name i'll just
call it cloudwatch permissions and
create the policy now we do need to edit
the trust relationship it's not actually
ec2 that's going to assume this role so
coming back here the trust policy can be
replaced we can literally just copy this
piece of text here
and we're going to paste it over where
it says ec2.amazonaws.com
so now the service that is able to
assume this role is vpc flow logs
let's update that trust policy that's it
we're now ready to go and create our
flow log back in ec2 i've only got one
instance running so it's going to be
easy to identify the network interface
we're going to create the flow log here
at the network interface level
so flick over to flow logs
create flow log i'll just call it my
flow log let's put it for all traffic
and a one-minute aggregation so we get
some data nice and fast we'll delete it
afterwards when we terminate our
instance anyway
and we're going to send to cloudwatch
logs so we've got our log group
and let's find our role which is starts
with flow so it's flow logs cloudwatch
and we're going to leave the default
format
and then just create that flow log
so now let's try a couple of things
we want to send some successful
connections so let's copy our public ip
go to a
new window here and put that in and
we've now generated some http traffic i
might refresh that a couple of times
and what about sending some traffic
which we're going to get rejected on
that's another thing that we could do
so let's come back to instances
check out what security group this
instance is in and it's actually got two
so let's go to the public web one
because i think that's the one that's
got some rules which allow certain
protocols from the internet and yes we
can see the ssh and http rules are in
there so let's go and edit the inbound
rules and i'm just going to temporarily
delete my ssh rule
and save
now from a command line i'm simply going
to try without any arguments to ssh to
that instance and that shouldn't work it
should just keep failing because we
don't have the security group rules to
allow this
so that's basically it just generating a
bit of traffic so what we can do now is
go to cloudwatch logs and see if some
data is starting to be sent there back
in cloudwatch logs i'm going to select
my log group
and let's see if we've got a stream and
i do have a stream that's nice and fast
now don't worry if it's not there yet
you might have to wait a few minutes and
it will turn up
so let's select my log stream
and see what data we have in here and
you can see there's a few entries here
we can see some rejects and associated
with those is various information
including the elastic network interface
the source and destination ip addresses
we've got port numbers we've got
protocol numbers we've got various bits
of information in there that could be
useful in whatever analysis you're doing
if you want to refresh you can click on
resume
and then you should see some more data
coming in over time
so there we go we've got quite a few
more rejects coming in as well and just
a couple of minutes later i've refreshed
my screen and we can see some accepts as
well so there's quite a few we can see
the port number here port 80 so those
are successful connections going to our
web server
so that's it there's lots of data there
that you can use for various analysis
and it's really useful to understand the
different types of logs we've got in aws
and what data is included in them so you
know which ones to use for your
troubleshooting or your analysis
so that's it for this lesson and we have
finished with our ec2 instance now so we
can go ahead and delete it
once you've terminated your instance
you're all cleaned up
[Music]
you